as your face is in a cloud of kool-aid
there's a sense of being in a different
world maybe in all of our lives there
are moments where anything sort of feels
possible the man with his face in the
kool-aid is David Edwards he's a
professor at Harvard University but
probably better known as an inventor
most of his inventions are a new twist
on how we take in nutrition for instance
this cloud comes from a creation of his
called the woth so what is a wife the
wife is a kind of is a carafe I pour in
my favorite liquid and then it begins to
create a cloud of in this case Scotch
sip it into my mouth
there's actually a really significant
aromatic experience but the wofe is
hardly David's only creation we have
what's called the air oh it's breathable
nutrition I do a little puff and I have
a burst of energy or immunity or
whatever the particular nutrition is the
Oh fondue oh it's a little bit like a
printer of aroma we have a apricot aroma
which I love with his whimsical food
creations in that gene Wilder hair it's
hard not to compare David to Willy Wonka
but we don't live in a world of pure
imagination and in reality David said
trouble marketing his ideas on a large
scale it's very hard to bring those
innovations immediately into a
mass-market environment so this led me
to the notion that we need an
environment a fully immersive
environment what I think of as kind of
an Apple store of nutrition where one
can enter and immediately believe that
one's in the future
this is his solution cafe art science a
new restaurant that he's opened up in
Cambridge Massachusetts the cafe serves
traditional food but more importantly it
functions as a showcase for David's
inventions over the last thirty years a
world has become very sympathetic
so there is an ambition of the cafe to
be a complete immersive environment for
the senses one of his more popular
creations are these little balls of ice
cream they're encased in an edible
packaging David invented called wiki
foods in one case we have a coffee this
is an expresso skin around a vanilla ice
cream axis a chocolate ice cream I
didn't know that but you can see it's
actually very good I began to think
about how one might encapsulate foods
and beverages like nature encapsulate
fruit you can't take the membrane off of
a cell as to have a cell and sorry can't
take my skin off of me and still have me
really and so why can you take a package
off of a bar of chocolate and have a bar
chocolate it's proposing a fundamental
change and how we make food how we
distribute food and consume food David
partnered with Stonyfield to sell wiki
encapsulated frozen yogurt but retailers
were hesitant to sell frozen foods
without packaging so the solution was to
encase them in a biodegradable wrapping
but this kind of defeated the purpose of
using the wiki cells in the first place
I've had many cases where we've had
revolutionary way of doing things
differently they were better for people
better for the environment but just the
inertia of the system kills the idea
many of these inventions probably have
trouble catching on because they just
seem like novelties but David believes
that the best way to start his food
revolution is to keep the conversation
fun changing the world is serious
business actually it can be sort of
frightening to face the fact that the
world is not going to be tomorrow what
it is today and so there needs to be I
believe
just opening up people's minds to the
joy of discovering tomorrow even if we
don't quite know what that tomorrow will
be
you